أنهت سلطات إنفاذ القانون في تكساس مطاردة منخفضة السرعة ومواجهة استمرت
لساعات مع
سائق هذه الشاحنة المقطورة،
وأغلقت العملية جميع الممرات على
الطريق السريع 10 في هيوستن حيث قام الضباط
بنشر مسامير الإطارات التي تدخن
كلاب الشرطة وحتى هذه السيارة المجهزة بذراع الرافعة
المستخدمة ل  تمزيق أجزاء من
كابينة الشاحنة، لقد كان مشهدًا صعبًا للغاية
خاصةً لأنه استمر في
المقاومة حتى مع انتشار الغاز، كما
تعلمون في معظم الأحيان، كلا الشخصين اللذين يعانيان من أنه سام
جدًا
وسيخرجان بسرعة كبيرة لا يبدو أنهما
كذلك  يواجههم الضباط ليسوا متأكدين بعد مما
إذا كانت الشاحنة مسروقة أو ما إذا كان السائق
يعمل في شركة الشاحنات، وتقول الشرطة
إنه بدا وكأنه مغطى بالزجاج
وظل في وضع القيادة يقوم بتسريع
المحرك حتى عندما حاول الضباط
إخراجه من السيارة.  السيارة وفقًا
لعمدة مقاطعة هاريس، قال الشريف إن
السائق يتلقى
رعاية طبية ولا تزال التهم معلقة